today for our daily cancellation we turn
our gaze to a woman called test holiday
a morbidly obese woman who
identifies as a model holliday has been
a plus-size model
and body acceptance advocate for many
years she feels very strongly that
obesity is a wonderful thing
and we should encourage more of it
basically tess holliday will be dead
before the age of 60 and she very much
wants you to join her
in this act of suicide and i understand
that may seem like a harsh way of
putting it but
encouraging morbid obesity is an awful
dangerous thing to do
and i think we need to be very
exceedingly clear about that
test holiday is easily 200 pounds
overweight
from the looks of it maybe more than
that nobody gets to that point naturally
nobody is born that way that isn't a
thyroid condition you have to spend many
years eating a lot of food
and getting very little exercise in
order to achieve that sort of size
and that's why we have in the past and
should continue to
put a stigma on morbid obesity yeah
there should be a stigma
it's not the look that we're
stigmatizing it's sloth
and gluttony which is what leads to
morbid obesity
why do we stigmatize sloth and gluttony
well because that
those qualities will make you miserable
and unhappy and unhealthy and eventually
kill you so yeah we should stigmatize it
so when we say that tess holliday is an
obesity advocate what we really mean is
that she advocates the behaviors the
self-destructive suicidal behaviors
that lead to obesity and for that she
should be
thoroughly shamed and condemned
she doesn't care about body positivity
anyway much less self-love she is merely
trying to justify
and feel better about her own vices by
encouraging others to join her in them
misery loves company it's it's a truth
as old as time
now these are all true statements about
tess holliday but we we were never
supposed to say any of that out loud and
and now we're even
more so supposed to shut up about it
given that test holiday
has found a new way to make a victim of
herself the morbidly obese woman
announced on twitter a few days ago
that she's in recovery for anorexia
and we have to say that her recovery
appears to be going
pretty well here's what she said reading
from the daily wire article it says plus
size model and fat activist tess
holliday revealed last week
that she has anorexia and is in recovery
quote i'm anorexic and i'm in recovery
i'm not ashamed to say it out loud
anymore i'm the result of a culture that
celebrates thinness and equates that to
worth but i get to write my own
narrative now
i'm finally able to care for a body that
i've punished my entire life and i'm
finally free
and then she continued not the but
you're fat how are you anorexic comments
y'all don't know
how science and bodies work do you my
technical diagnosis is anorexia nervosa
and yes i'm still not ashamed i'm too
damn happy for y'all to even come close
to dimming my shine
responding to criticism concerning
holiday's body acceptance activism she
said quote
to everyone saying that i can't possibly
love myself and have an eating disorder
that is the actual definition of loving
myself being able to
prioritize myself and be in recovery i'm
more self-aware than any of my critics
but you know you all go off
an instagram post holiday similarly
talked about her weight and scolded
people who tell her that she looks
healthy lately
quote to everyone that keeps saying
you're looking healthy lately or you're
losing weight keep it up
stop don't comment on my weight or
perceived health keep it to
yourself thanks periods in between all
those
words um okay now yeah
don't comment on test holiday's weight
none of your business
i mean tess holliday poses half naked in
front of cameras every day talks about
her weight
brags about her body constantly shares
all kinds of information and imagery
with the public
that none of us asked to know or see i
mean we're trying to go about our lives
and test holiday is always running up
with a bullhorn shouting hey guys
let me tell you more about my body
anyone want to hear
and yet it's none of our business we
aren't supposed to talk about it
well perhaps tess holiday needs to
choose a lane here
if you're a private person living your
everyday life minding your own business
and somebody comes up to you as you walk
down the street and tells you that
you're fat
then sure that person's probably a bully
but if you go up to someone else
who's minding their own business and say
hi i'm fat isn't that great
they are well within their rights to
respond and say no ma'am it's not great
it's not attractive it's not healthy
and you're going to die soon you might
not like that answer but you brought it
up
don't want to hear the answer then don't
bring it up
this is a this is the rule anything you
say to me
anything you bring up to me i am allowed
to have an
opinion about if you don't want to hear
my opinion
don't tell me if you don't want to hear
the public's opinion
don't tell the public
but what about this claim that she's
anorexic i mean how can that be
good morning america did a segment on
the issue a few days ago
where they interviewed test holiday and
here's what she said about it
this morning supermodel test holiday
revealing her struggle with anorexia
the mother of two saying she was
recently diagnosed by a psychologist
but has ultimately been struggling with
disordered eating
most of her life i always thought that i
over
ate but then people in my life would say
oh yeah i eat more than tests and it was
almost like i wore it as a badge of
honor
known for loving and celebrating her
curves as a body positive activist
holliday has been receiving support for
her honesty for many
but also being questioned by some online
about how she could love her body and
also
have an eating disorder i've had a lot
of messages from folks that are anorexic
that are
livid and angry because they feel like
i'm lying i am plus-sized but advocating
for
diversity in larger bodies and so i
think
for people hearing me say i'm anorexic
was really jarring holidays dietitian
anna sweeney says
if you think that most eating disorders
are visible conditions
you're wrong eating disorders don't have
to look
a certain way i understand that people
look at me and i don't fit
what we have seen presented as you know
the diagnosis for anorexia
but then for me that tells me that
there's
a larger problem which i've been
actually saying for years is that
we have a like a lack of diversity and
representation
in the world oh my gosh we need
more diversity and representation in
eating disorders
that's what she just said for too long
skinny women have been getting all the
anorexic attention
test holiday believes that she's owed
some of that attention too
why should they be getting this
attention i'm here well i want attention
to
she believes that she's owed attention
for being too fat and too skinny at the
same time
she also seems to think she's stumbled
on a good excuse here she says that
she thought she thought she was
overeating and frankly the evidence for
that theory is pretty good i have to say
but
then she realized that she's anorexic so
if anything she's under eating
it's a clever trick you have to admit
now obviously a 300 plus pound woman
would not qualify under any coherent
definition of the term
as anorexic the the very term anorexia
comes from the greek
meaning without appetite that's what
anorexia means
without appetite that is evidently
not test holiday's problem but anorexia
is a mental illness and as we've
discussed in this segment a few times
recently
mental illness is a category
experiencing its own
rapid inflation shall we say a great
many
mental illnesses are simply medical
labels for normal
human behaviors and even many of the
ones that describe some kind of
legitimate condition
have been expanded now into near
meaninglessness
anorexia is the perfect example listen
to the latest definition of anorex
anorexia provided by the website
nationaleatingdisorders.org
to be diagnosed with anorexia uh or
rather anorexia nervosa according to the
dsm-5
the following criteria must be met one
restriction of energy intake relative to
requirements leading to a significantly
low body weight in the context of age
sex developmental trajectory and
physical health
intense fear of gaining weight or
becoming fat even though underweight
so far so sensible that's what you
imagine when you think of an anorexic
person right underweight
little appetite not eating much afraid
of getting fat
etc but then there's the third
definition
added recently quote disturbance in the
way in which one's body weight or shape
is experienced
undue influence of body weight or shape
on self-evaluation
or denial of the seriousness of the
current low body weight
well there it is undue influence of body
weight or
shape on self-evaluation in other words
everyone is anorexic did you know that
you're anorexic so am i we all are
welcome to the club every single person
on earth is anorexic
because it could be argued that all of
us at least one point or another
have been overly concerned about our
body weight or shape
what counts as undue influence i mean
how much influence is due
and who decides that who decides when
it's undue
well nobody does it's all subjective
it's all arbitrary it's a
one-size-fits-all label
that's the point we live in a culture
where many people are desperate to be
victims desperate to relieve themselves
of the burden of
agency and self-determination
unfortunately the medical industry is
more than happy to oblige
which is how tess holliday gets to be a
morbid obese potty body positivity
advocate
who brags about her obesity yet at the
same time is not responsible for obesity
because somehow it's a symptom of a
disorder which for everyone else causes
a catastrophic loss of body weight
it doesn't make any sense at all no
sense
but it's not supposed to this is what
makes tess holliday
feel the best about best about herself
and her choices and that's all that
matters
that's all that matters
so for that reason we have to say that
test holiday today
is canceled listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated